هذه السيده جاءت للتو من هاتاي وهي متعبه
ومريضه واود ليال سريعا ان نستمع الى
مشكلتها وما الذي تعاني منه الحمد لله على
السلامه اولا يلا يسلمك حضرتك كنت وقت وقت
الزلزال بالبيت كنت بالبيت وقعت على وجهي
ضليت بالجوع يعني
بالغرفه نعم لا راحت الهزه احسنتن زين من
هالدرج كمان هالرده
وقفنا تحت المطر
طول الليل
وبعدهم جينا الصبحيات عبيتنا
رجعنا يعني
اغراضي كله
البيت البيت انهدم لا الحمد لله ما ندم بس
يعني اتضرر
طيب انت انت مريضه او ايش مالك
انا بعتوني من سوريا من مستشفى مستشفى
المركزي يعني انت جئت من سوريا سكنتي في
انطاكيا حدث الزلزال للعلاج يعني
هذا نصر العلاج بسوريا وحولوني لها ونكمل
علاجي ولما جيتي صار الزلزال يوم اللي بده
يروح جاء دوري بده يدخل على المستشفى صار
الزلزال لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله صار لي
فيديو شهر هلا تعبانه وجسمي ما عم بحسن
وما حيلي سلامتك طب انت ايش المشكله
الصحيه اللي عندك ايش بوجعك اول
[موسيقى]
شيء
بنات توجعني كثير معدتي ولا بقى احسن يقبل
اكل ولا اشرب وناكل اكلت
راسا سلامتك الف سلامه يعني انت الان
تحتاجي لنقل الى المستشفى مستشفى مختص
بالسرطان ضروري ايه
على شاشه العربيه وان شاء الله ويكون صوتك
وصل ونحن في مركز ايواء مركز حماه هنا في
انطاكيا في في هاتاي تعبان كتير كتير